chers compatriotes 5 millions de 168
1613 françaises et français m'ont fait
confiance au premier tour de scrutin
ils m'ont ainsi fait l'honneur d'être le
candidat au deuxième tour candidat pour
le changement pour la défense de la
démocratie républicaine la défense de
vos libertés est tout simplement
candidats pour l'honnêteté politique
vous allez fixer votre destin pour sept
ans entre monsieur pompidou et moi
s'engage un grand débat national
de son issue dépend l'avenir de chacun
d'entre vous en un mot l'avenir de la
france le choix est simple continuer le
passé monsieur pompidou n'at-il pas été
entre 1962 et 1968 premier ministre 1 et
il a effectué six ans de pouvoir
certains ont dit six ans de pouvoir
personnel et moi je propose un
changement politique profond changement
de méthode politique changement
d'orientation de l'état c'est d'ailleurs
ce que veulent les français puisque 53%
d'entre eux se sont prononcés pour le
non au référendum et que le 1er juin 56
% ont confirmé cette volonté
les français veulent que cela change
et c'est pourquoi je n'ai pas envisagé
hu a condamné dix une seconde de me
retirer
d'abord parce que la constitution
prévoit que les deux candidats arrivés
en tête au premier tour se maintiennent
pour le deuxième tour
le journal officiel l'a confirmé ce
matin
chers compatriotes si vous m'aidez pour
défendre votre désir de changement pour
défendre le retour nécessaire au
dialogue une gestion plus raisonnable de
l'économie du pays
l'avenir de vos enfants et la justice
sociale la paix du monde par l'europe
unie si vous vous mobilisez à mes côtés
pour défendre ma candidature parler de
moi autour de vous à vos amis à vos
parents la victoire est encore possible
croyez moi qu'importe la pauvreté de mes
moyens et la richesse l'opulence même de
ceux des autres valeurs d'un programme
ou d'un candidat ne se mesure pas au
nombre d' affiches apposées sur les murs
à la peinture répandue sur le sol
en matière électorale la pauvreté c'est
la liberté
chers compatriotes si vous le voulez
vous pourrez avec moi mener une nouvelle
bataille du non celle du non à monsieur
pompidou à quoi voulez abouti et
monsieur pompidou en demandant mon
retrait que voulaient les bons esprits
qui m'ont si longuement demandé de me
désister ou de partir est ce qu'il
voulait obtenir pour monsieur duclos un
succès plus important 35 à 40 % des
suffrages
est ce qu'ils voulaient éviter de faire
mentir monsieur malraux qui a dit un
jour qu'il n'y avait plus rien en france
entre le gaullisme et le communisme
et bien si mes chers amis il y en a en
france
ce courant national que j'incarne avec
vous et qui créent maintenant une
véritable innovation politique pour la
défense de la république
revenons-en à ce combat monsieur
pompidou
a gouverné pendant six ans je vous dit
tout à l'heure la france ne connaît bien
pour ma part je n'ai pas confiance en sa
politique
il veut tout changer dit-il pourquoi
n'at-il pas fait hier quand il était au
pouvoir
nous nous voulons d'abord libérer la
république de l'emprise d'un plan et
remette de l'ordre dans l'état
nous voulons près simplement éviter la
colonisation de l'état après tout qui
est responsable des polices parallèles
financée par des ressources inavoués qui
a donné des cartes de policiers à des
truands et qui payent tous ces gens là
jean de sac et de corde qui responsable
des pressions sur la magistrature qui
n'a pas supprimé les juridictions
d'exception et qui a favorisé la
nomination rapide des magistrats qui
accepté de siéger dans cette juridiction
spéciale en matière de subventions
collectivités locales qui responsable un
certain favoritisme
n'at-on pas entendu dans une campagne
est drôle la dernière campagne
municipale des candidats pouvoir dire
que si on ne votait pas pour le liste la
ville serait privé et d'équipements eux
dans l'on parle de lower tf lower tf1
formation des guides et opinions de
l'euro fort mais nous en reparlons dans
une autre émission mais également la
mainmise sur l'état des agents de l'état
qui deviennent les agents de propagande
pourquoi ne pas parler non plus de
l'absence de dialogue dans les
assemblées du parlement
les votes bloqués l'administration qui
gouverne à la place du gouvernement et
du parlement
il faudrait à mon sens et c'est notre
devoir libérer aussi les français des
charges écrasantes qui pèsent sur leurs
économies et puise la monnaie et menace
le climat social
le plein emploi
les impôts sous la gestion de monsieur
pompidou l'impôt direct a augmenté de 50
% l'impôt indirect de 80% et si on nous
dit aujourd'hui qu'on va à dégrevé un
million d'assujettis à l'impôt général
sur le revenu une faute de même
considérer qu'en 1962 il n'y avait que 3
millions de cotisants maintenant il y en
a 10 il en restera au moins millions le
chômage non de chômeurs que les 256
milles en 1962 est à 30 juin 68 2 540
mille ont remarqué ce ne sont des
exemples gens présents très bien d'eau
dans les émissions suivantes
je proposerai les solutions du
redressement par le progrès la sécurité
la france sur huisne par ses dépenses de
prestige et sa puissance industrielle
est en retard quand on regarde à côté de
nous en allemagne ou en italie
non seulement nous prenons du retard
mais nous sommes dépassés dans toutes
les statistiques il faut arracher la
france a cédé gestion malsaine qui
détruit sa vitalité
l'europe est à des moyens par l'europe
la france peut retrouver demain la vraie
voie monsieur pompidou promet le
redressement ailleurs il promet tout
mais je n'ai pas confiance dans cet
ancien ministre qui r&d de pouvoir et
qui oublie ses responsabilités d'autres
fois c'est pourquoi en définitive j'ai
maintenu ma candidature
après va parler de la gestion parlons
aussi de l'entourage les ultras du
gaullisme et cette majorité unie il va
de capitan à giscard d'estaing en
passant par san miletti foccart debré
ducatel tixier vignancour et duhamel
duhamel qui me combat aujourd'hui après
m'avoir soutenu hier il ya une certaine
démagogie aussi dans les exposés qui
sont faits
si je prends le cas des commerçants et
artisans on leur promet maintenant le
salaire fiscal qu'on leur
ayez la réforme de la tva et de
l'assurance maladie qu'on a fait voter
et maintenant à l'ordre du jour
l'agriculteur on leur promet une
amélioration du revenu de l'exploitation
familiale que ne l'at on fait plutôt les
anciens combattants égalité règlement du
contentieux aux collectivités locales
une meilleure répartition des charges
entre l'état le département et les
communes
mais tout ça a aidé au programme d'hier
et on ne l'a pas fait quant aux
européens on leur promet l'europe unie
mais pourtant qui est responsable des
crises graves de 63 65 67
chaque voyage en province permet de
connaître des nouvelles promesses
d'autoroute d'équipement de tout genre
mais tout ceci coûte d'argent j'ai pu
chiffrer à près de 2000 milliards
d'anciens francs par an toutes ses
dépenses mais le budget est déjà en
déséquilibre près de 1000 à 12 100
milliards qui paiera tout cela qui en
effectif sinon le pays réglera les
étrennes de monsieur pompidou face à un
candidat qui a oublié sa gestion passée
et qui maintenant fait beaucoup de
promesses
moi je vous ai offert un contrat en 12
points qui a été publiée avant le
premier tour
j'affirme vouloir défendre la volonté
des français de restaurer les libertés
et la réconciliation de tous
j'ai vous le savez une conception
nouvelle du rôle de chef de l'état qui
est d'ailleurs celle qui existe dans la
constitution de 1958
le chef de l'état garant arbitre
animateurs car nous ne voulons pas
revoir ce pouvoir arrogant et solitaire
qui nous a mené où nous sommes
pompidou mais chez pompidou invoque la
menace du désordre
l'argument est d'ailleurs assez usé
avant le référendum menaçait et avec
l'aide du gouvernement comme président
de la république intérimaire
l'ordre a été assurée et il n'y a pas eu
de chaos comme je vous l'avais promis
mais qu'on ne s'y trompe pas la france
n'est calme que parce qu'elle attend une
gestion nouvelle
et si l'on attende était frustré il
n'est pas sûr qu'elle conserve tout son
calme car une france paralysée par le
retour au pouvoir d'un clan dominateur
serait une france sans repos il y aurait
risque de désordre dans ce cas lord je
vous la firme n'est valable que lorsqu
il repose sur la justice et il ne peut
se maintenir dans le cas contraire que
par la répression
c'est cette fatalité de la violence
qu'il faut rompre en restaurant la
démocratie et la justice sociale le
dialogue avec toutes les catégories
sociales
il faut se préoccuper du sort des
français du sort des travailleurs qui
paraissent un peu oublié dans tout ça de
leurs problèmes quotidiens de leur
angoisse devant le chômage et la vie
chère
comment rech plus dans ces conditions-là
abandonner la lutte mais j'ai eu aussi
des problèmes personnels et je veux les
évoqué par des milliers de tracts ainsi
chantage nationale on m'a dit femmes et
calomnié couverts de boue ma famille
elle-même n'a pas été épargné faux
résistants 10 et on vous écrivez ton
hier mes camarades de lutte
comprendre 20 compagnons de la
libération sont venus me rendre justice
faucon bâton marc en guerre 39-45 et
elle pas déjà un témoignage agents
d'étrangers complice des nazis candidat
qui voulait 10 et on rendre l'alsace
française à l'allemagne on a osé envoyer
de tels tracts en alsace française homme
de bonne de bruxelles
d'israël je ne sais c'en est assez pour
un seul homme on peut être patriote et
avoir des amis à l'étranger beaucoup
d'amis à l'étranger en aimant sa patrie
clérical francs-maçons tout à la fois
adversaires de l'école libre adversaires
de la laïcité
j'en passe mais serait ce un déshonneur
d'être catholique et tolérants envers
toutes les opinions en particulier bien
sûr celle des autres incapable médiocre
ridicule mais je m'honore d'avoir été
élu plusieurs fois président du
parlement européen par l'unanimité des
délégués français à strasbourg y compris
les voix de leader au tout ça c'est déjà
le passé et je remercie monsieur
pompidou d'avoir fière fait justice de
ces accusations et d'avoir tenu lui
aussi à ce que la campagne reste décente
je demande à mes amis je demande même à
mes adversaires de contredire toutes ces
propos diffamatoires qui croyez moi sont
indignes cette campagne électorale
en ce qui me concerne ma campagne à moi
restera ce qu'elle a été une campagne
d'idées une campagne politique et non
pas une campagne personnelle et je
développerai successivement tous les
thèmes que j'ouvrirais les douches et
que je dois ouvrir car vous avez à élire
un président de la république à choisir
entre pompidou ou poèmes pour libérer la
france du clan politique qui la domine
pour redresser son économie en péril
pour lui rendre ses libertés et défendre
la république pour que la vème
république celle de la constitution de
1958 soit la république de tous les
citoyens et de tous les français vous me
ferez confiance le 15 juin prochain
merci mes chers compatriotes
[Musique]